Wie oft bei guten Geschichten,
beginnt auch diese mit einer Legende:
Im jurassischen Dorf La Sagne
gab im 17. Jh. ein Pferdehändler
seine kaputte englische Uhr
einem Einheimischen zum Flicken.
Dem jungen Schmid Daniel Jean Richard
gelang die Reparatur.
Darauf beschloss er,
selber Uhren zu bauen.
Und so begann es
mit der Schweizer Uhrenindustrie.
Ich bin unterwegs im Jura.
In den abgelegenen Täler und
Hochebenen, in denen die Menschen
seit 400 Jahren
eines der feinsten Handwerke pflegen.
Von hier kommen hoch komplizierte,
teure und sehr erfolgreiche Uhren.
Das, nachdem die Schweiz das Wett-
rennen um die besten Uhren der Welt,
schon fast für immer verloren hatte.
Mein erstes Ziel
liegt im Waadtländer Jura.
Ich bin zu Gast bei Breguet,
eine der ältesten und weltweit
renommiertesten Uhrenmanufakturen.
Guten Tag, Herr Hayek!
Guten Tag und herzlich Willkommen!
Hausherr ist Marc Hayek.
Er ist der Enkel des grossen
Uhrenindustriellen Nicolas Hayek.
Nach dem Tod des Grossvaters
übernahm er 2010 die Leitung.
Breguet ist eine Manufaktur
für Luxusuhren,
eine von vielen Firmen
des Swatch-Konzerns.
Hier werden die Kanten gebrochen
und poliert.
Auf der anderen Seite
wird für mich der Uhr
bereits ein Stück der Seele gegeben.
Fast alles, was zu einer Uhr gehört,
wird hier gemacht.
Rund 50 verschiedene Berufe
sind hier vertreten.
Die meisten der Angestellten
sind Fachleute.
Ein paar davon pflegen
jahrhundertealte Berufe.
Hier wird z.T. auch
mit alten Maschinen gearbeitet.
Sind wir hier
an einem sehr speziellen Ort?
Was heisst Guillochage?
Das ist eine Art von Gravur.
Das Gravurmesser wird eingespannt,
der Druck bestimmt die Tiefe.
Dann wird das Zifferblatt in Wellen
und verschiedenen Formen graviert.
Sehr wenige Manufakturen machen das.
Warum machen Sie das?
Das ist ein sehr, sehr
wichtiger Punkt bei der Breguet.
Alle unsere Zifferblätter
sind handguillochiert.
Das gehört sozusagen zu unserer DNA.
Ausserdem behält es auch
das Handwerk am Leben.
Für mich ist das mehr als nur etwas,
das die Marke braucht.
Die Industrie braucht das.
Wir behalten das nicht am Leben
mit jemandem,
der das an einem Einzelstück macht,
sondern es ist ein Beruf.
Wir produzieren hier richtig. Der
Beruf muss am Leben erhalten werden.
Abraham Louis Breguet
hat mit seinen Erfindungen
Massstäbe gesetzt für die
Präzisionsuhrmacherei - bis heute.
Der spröde Neuenburger
ist im 18. Jh. ausgewandert
und machte in Paris
eine grosse Karriere.
Königin Marie Antoinette, Napoleon
Bonaparte und russische Zaren
haben seine kostbaren Uhren begehrt.
Später kamen Grössen
wie Winston Churchill
oder der Starpianist
Arthur Rubinstein dazu.
Es ist die Handarbeit,
die die Breguet-Uhren so teuer
und exklusiv macht,
erklärt mir Marc Hayek.
Er zeigt mir ein Modell,
das mehrere 100'000 Fr. kostet.
Das hier ist die Double Tourbillon
als Extrem.
Für mich ist es Leben wie Kunst,
denn ich habe mit einer mechanischen
Uhr ein ewiges Leben.
Solange ich das "Savoir-faire" habe,
um die Uhr zu reparieren -
das Material und das Gedächtnis -
kann ich sie am Leben erhalten.
Ihr Grossvater sagte: "Die Chinesen
können nie ein Breguet-Uhr machen."
Was sagen Sie?
Natürlich sieht man Kopien.
Aber da kommen wir wieder
zum selben Punkt.
Nützlich, wenn sie mehr oder weniger
so aussieht und ticktack macht.
Okay.
Wenn ich einen Picasso kopiere,
habe ich auch ein Ebenbild,
aber ich habe keinen Picasso.
Es gibt nur ein Original.
Es ist eine Kulturfrage
und es braucht, von mir aus gesehen,
Generationen.
In dem Moment, in dem wir aufhören
bei uns zu investieren,
Innovationen zu machen,
Technologien vorwärtszutreiben,
dann sind wir wahrscheinlich
in 20 - 30 Jahren tot.
Nicolas Hayek
hat Breguet 1999 gekauft.
Etwas, das er sofort
in Angriff nahm, war,
die komplizierte Uhr nachzubauen,
die Breguet seinerzeit für Königin
Marie Antoinette gemacht hatte.
Mit seinem unschlagbaren Sinn
für den grossen Auftritt,
hat er die Uhr im In- und Ausland
immer wieder präsentiert.
Sie hat einen riesigen Wert.
Es ist ein Einzelstück.
Aus diesem Atelier kommt diese Uhr.
Die Spezialisten
arbeiten heute an einem Modell,
das Marie Antoinette
übertreffen soll:
an einer Uhr
zu Ehren von Nicolas Hayek.
Die Grande Complication
ist unser grosses Projekt.
Was ist speziell an dieser Uhr?
Es hat über 2'000 Einzelteile
in der Uhr.
Es hat ein Tourbillon, eine Grande
Sonnerie, eine Petite Sonnerie,
eine Minutenrepetition,
einen Tag- und Nachtalarm.
Der Alarm funktioniert
auf der Grande Sonnerie.
Er verändert sich je nach Tageszeit.
Was kostet sie etwa?
Wir denken,
wir kommen so gegen 2 Mio. Fr.
Wir haben keine grosse Marge.
Trotz diesem Preis
wird man damit nicht reich.
Aber das Herz ist dabei,
wenn man so etwas miterleben kann.
Das ist etwas sehr Spezielles.
Und das ist schön.
Dann führt mich Marc Hayek
zu einer lebenden Legende im Betrieb:
zum Uhrmacher Louis Caillet.
Dank Menschen wie ihm
hat Breguet überlebt.
Bonjour monsieur, comment ca va?
Bonjour!
Bonjour monsieur!
Votre nom est?
Caillet.
Monsieur Caillet.
Sind Sie schon lange hier?
Ja, seit 44 Jahren.
Es gibt sicher nicht viele,
die schon 44 Jahre hier sind?
Nein, das ist ein Rekord
und lebende Geschichte.
Auch von der Familie her
ist es eine lange Geschichte.
Schon sein Grossvater
hat mit Breguet zusammengearbeitet.
Das ist sehr, sehr selten.
Ich möchte über Louis Caillet
mehr wissen und gehe zu ihm heim.
Sein Haus
steht gleich neben der Fabrik.
Hier ist er geboren,
hier hat er sein Leben lang gewohnt.
So wie sein Vater
und sein Grossvater.
Louis Caillet stammt
von französischen Hugenotten ab,
die im 16. und 17. Jh.
in den Jura flüchteten.
Das ist der Coiffeursalon
meines Grossvaters,
den mein Vater übernahm.
Mitte der 1950er-Jahre
schloss er das Geschäft
und begann im oberen Stock,
als Uhrmacher zu arbeiten.
Als ich noch ganz klein war, setzte
ich mich jeweils schon frühmorgens
auf seinen Schoss,
um ihm bei der Arbeit zuzuschauen.
Damit ich überhaupt etwas sah,
musste er das Knie etwas anheben.
Was er mit den Uhren machte,
verstand ich damals
natürlich noch nicht.
Louis Caillet kommt aus
einer regelrechten Uhrmacherfamilie.
Viele seiner Vorfahren und Verwandten
haben schon als Uhrmacher gearbeitet.
Ihn selber hat das Handwerk
schon als kleiner Bub fasziniert.
An Weihnachten wünschte ich mir
einmal einen alten Wecker.
Um ihn auseinanderzunehmen,
zu verstehen, wozu die Räder dienen.
Da sagte meine Mutter: "Wo soll ich
den finden, diesen alten Wecker?"
Und dann?
Und dann? Ja, und dann suchte ich
im Abfall nach solchen Dingen.
Auch Louis Caillets Mutter
hat Teilzeit
in einer Uhrenfabrik gearbeitet -
wie die meisten Bewohner
des Vallee de Joux.
Kann man sagen, dass die Leute hier
eine besondere Begabung
für dieses Handwerk haben?
Ich glaube,
sie wurden dazu gezwungen.
Es gab ja nichts hier.
Im Winter konnten die Leute
nirgendwo hin, wegen des Schnees.
Viele von ihnen waren Bauern
und beschäftigten sich
in den langen Wintermonaten
zu Hause mit der Uhrmacherei.
Sie hatten auf dem Hof
kleine Ateliers mit vielen Fenstern,
damit sie genügend Licht hatten
für die knifflige Arbeit.
So fertigten sie im Auftrag
von Firmen Uhrenbestandteile an.
Die Siedlungen sind weit verstreut
in den Tälern des Jura.
Die Menschen sind
freiheitsliebend und eigenständig.
Und sie haben eine hohe Arbeitsmoral.
Das Handwerk, das die Hugenotten aus
Frankreich in die Schweiz brachten,
fand im Jura und bei den Jurassiern
die ideale Heimat.
Wie ideal, verstehe ich erst in
La Chaux-de-Fonds im Neuenburger Jura
Hier treffe ich Ludwig Oechslin.
Er ist Uhrmacher und leitet hier
das Internationale Uhrenmuseum.
Die Stadt ist geprägt
von der Uhrenindustrie.
Darum wurde sie vor ein paar Jahren
ins UNESCO-Weltkulturerbe
aufgenommen.
Vom höchsten Turm im Ort
erklärt er mir die Zusammenhänge.
Kann man sagen,
dass La Chaux-de-Fonds
wegen der Uhrenindustrie so aussieht?
Ja, aber man kann nicht sagen,
La Chaux-de-Fonds sei am Reissbrett
für die Uhrenindustrie entstanden.
Z.B. New York und San Francisco
sind in dieser Zeit
auch in diesem Schachbrettmuster
entstanden.
Speziell hier ist,
dass es für die Arbeit der Uhrmacher
so eingerichtet wurde:
mit den breiten Strassen,
den Vorgärten gegen Süden.
Das ist sicher sehr speziell.
Im 19. Jh. war die Schweiz
ein Billiglohnland,
darum seien die Uhren von hier
weltweit konkurrenzfähig geblieben,
meint Ludwig Oechslin.
Von der Architektur her typisch
sind die Arbeiterhäuschen
mit den langen Fensterreihen
im Obergeschoss.
Hinter diesen
waren die kleinen Uhrmacherateliers,
in denen Lehrlinge,
Frauen und Kinder gearbeitet haben.
Wegen ihren
flinken und feinen Händen
waren die Frauen für die Arbeit
besonders gefragt.
Auch die grosszügigen Gärten
stehen im Dienst dieses Handwerks.
Die Gärten wurden so angelegt, weil
man Raum und Licht geben wollte.
Raum geben, um gut zu leben,
offen leben mit genügend
Möglichkeiten, um draussen zu sein.
Und Licht geben
für die Arbeit selber,
weil von Süden her das meiste Licht
auf ihre Atelier trifft
durch die Fensterfront,
die gegen Süden ausgerichtet ist.
Die pompösen Fabrikantenvillen sind
Zeitzeugen vom Boom der Uhrmacherei.
Ende des 19. Jh.
entstanden die ersten Fabriken.
Die Schweizer Uhren haben dazumal
den Weltmarkt dominiert.
Was war Anfang des 20. Jh.
typisch hier in La Chaux-de-Fonds?
Typisch für La Chaux-de-Fond
ist bei diesem Gebäudekomplex
die extreme Durchmischung
von Lebens- und Arbeitsbereich.
Auf der einen Seite
direkt die Fabrik
und auf der anderen Seite sofort
angeschlossen das Fabrikantenhaus.
Dort hat der Chef dieser Fabrik
gewohnt.
La Chaux-de-Fond ist bis heute
von den Uhren geprägt.
Am Stadtrand haben sich
in den letzten Jahren
immer mehr bekannte Uhrenmarken
angesiedelt.
Auch ein kleines, äusserst
erfolgreiches Start-up kam hierher:
Greubel Forsey.
Aus einem alten Bauernhof haben
die englisch-französischen Besitzer
eine moderne Manufaktur gemacht.
Weshalb mit diesem Bauernhof?
Wir wollen uns damit zurückbesinnen
auf die Uhrmachertradition
in dieser Region.
Und auch den Sammlern unserer Uhren
ausserhalb der Schweiz
diese Wurzeln näher bringen.
Also ist es auch eine Art Marketing?
Nicht unbedingt.
Es ist wirklich ein Hinweis darauf,
dass die Uhren hier
früher so produziert wurden.
Wir verbinden das Alte mit einem
modernen Gebäude aus dem 21. Jh.,
das für uns
die Zukunft symbolisiert.
Sie haben diese beiden Elemente,
die sich perfekt ergänzen.
So wie bei unseren Uhren.
Auch da verbinden wir
die alte Uhrmachertradition
mit einer völlig neuen Technologie
und es harmoniert.
In ihrem modernen Glasbau
beschäftigen Greubel und Forsey
rund 70 Leute aus der Region.
Der Uhrmacher Stephen Forsey
hat das Handwerk ursprünglich
in England gelernt.
In der Schweiz
wollte er es perfektionieren
und lernte hier
den Elsässer Robert Greubel kennen.
2004 gründeten sie ihre eigene Marke.
Die junge Uhrenfirma
hat sich in enorm kurzer Zeit
im Luxussegment durchgesetzt.
Eine Uhr kostet
zwischen 350'000 und 850'000 Fr. -
ohne Edelsteine.
Ticken
Können Sie uns erklären,
was Ihre Uhren so teuer macht?
Nun, ich glaube nicht,
dass sie teuer sind.
Ich finde, sie sind teuer.
Jedenfalls,
ich könnte mir keine leisten.
Das ist allerdings etwas anderes.
Das will nicht heissen,
dass sie teuer sind.
Schauen Sie, eine Greubel-Forsey-Uhr
ist eine Art Unikat.
Wir produzieren nur
rund 100 Stück pro Jahr.
Das heisst, es steckt sehr,
sehr viel Arbeit dahinter.
Konzentration und Ruhe - etwas
vom Wichtigsten beim Uhrenhandwerk.
Wer braucht eine solche Uhr?
Wer braucht das?
Irgendwo sind es wir.
Wir haben diesen Willen, diese
Leidenschaft für das Uhrenhandwerk,
das seit Jahrhunderten besteht.
Es ist die Aufgabe der Uhrmachers,
dafür zu sorgen,
dass dieses Handwerk nicht verloren
geht und es voranzutreiben.
Das braucht Zeit und Energie.
Natürlich braucht es auch jene, die
bereit sind, dies zu unterstützen
und eine solche Uhr kaufen.
Es ist ein Zusammenspiel.
Wir sind im Internationalen
Uhrenmuseum in La Chaux-de-Fonds,
dem bedeutendsten der Welt.
Hier hütet Ludwig Oechslin
4'500 Schätze.
Hier sind die älteren Uhren,
z.B. mit diesem Herzstück.
Erotische Fantasien im Email ...
... oder ...
... Vögel, die singen
für den Kaiserhof von China.
Trällern
Die Schweizer Uhrenindustrie
konnte schnell auf Moden reagieren
und Sonderwünsche befriedigen.
Was passiert bei dieser Uhr?
Diese Uhr ist ein Planetarium.
Man kann im Zeitraffer die Planeten
um die Sonne kreisen lassen.
Die Sonne steht im Zentrum und
Merkur, Venus, die Erde mit Mond,
Mars, Jupiter, Saturn und Uranus,
ganz hinten,
stehen im Planetensystem
um die Sonne herum.
Wofür hat man
solch astronomische Uhren gebaut?
Diese hat man
aus didaktischen Gründen gebaut,
um der Bevölkerung zu zeigen,
wie so etwas funktioniert.
So konnten sie sich
eine Vorstellung davon machen.
Rein auch
vom philosophischen Standpunkt her.
Damit man auch sah,
in welcher Grössenordnung
man im Gesamtrahmen lebt.
Im Laufe der Zeit
wurden Uhren immer kleiner.
Von den Kirchturmuhren
über Tisch- zu Taschenuhren.
Und nach der Taschenuhr
kam im 20. Jh. die Armbanduhr.
Diese Taschenuhr wurde
in eine Lederfassung eingearbeitet,
damit man sie
über den Kleidern tragen konnte.
Dieser Trend hat sich im Laufe
des 1. Weltkriegs entwickelt.
Das insbesondere im Militärbereich.
In einem späteren Stadium auch,
um die Taschenuhr zu schützen.
Um die Armbanduhr zu schützen, hat
man solche Gitter darauf gemacht.
Insbesondere bei Offizieren,
die solche Uhren tragen konnten.
Es scheint ein Trendsetter
gewesen zu sein,
so dass eben auch viele andere Leute
die Uhr tragen wollten.
Nachher kam sie dann wirklich
ans Handgelenk unter den Kleidern.
Die Nachfrage nach Armbanduhren
nimmt immer mehr zu.
In Biel, Grenchen und Solothurn
entstehen neue Uhrenzentren.
1929 haben in der Schweiz
schon 50'000 Leute
in der Uhrenindustrie gearbeitet.
Nach der Krise in den 30er-Jahren
hat die Industrie im 2. Weltkrieg
wieder angezogen.
Die Schweiz konnte produzieren und
liefern, an die, die im Krieg waren.
Ein Kartell, das sog. Uhrenstatut,
hat sie vor der Konkurrenz geschützt.
Nach dem 2. Weltkrieg
kamen immer mehr Menschen
aus dem Ausland in die Fabriken.
V.a. italienische Frauen.
Sie waren meist unqualifiziert, wegen
ihren flinken Händen aber gefragt.
Ich besuche eine Arbeiterin
in Fleurier/NE,
die diese Jahre
hautnah miterlebt hat.
Valeria Generoso kam als 18-Jährige
von Italien in die Schweiz
und begann Mitte der 60er Jahre
in der Uhrenindustrie zu arbeiten.
La plus petite derriere.
Wir Ausländerinnen
hatten einen schlechteren Ansatz
als die Schweizerinnen,
d.h., wir verdienten weniger.
Da wir aber pro Stück bezahlt wurden
und schnell arbeiteten,
verdienten wir manchmal
mehr als die Schweizerinnen.
Sobald sie dies aber bemerkten,
reklamierten sie beim Chef.
Die Hochkonjunktur,
in den Jahren nach dem 2. Weltkrieg,
war für die Frauen harte
und v.a. monotone Arbeit.
Traurige Berühmtheit bekamen damals
die sog. Saridon-Brötchen.
Die Arbeiterinnen belegten ihre Brote
mit Tabletten
gegen die Kopfschmerzen.
Bessere Arbeitsumstände
musste man sich erkämpfen.
Da, wo ich gearbeitet habe,
wollten sie
nichts von Gewerkschaften wissen.
Das war indiskutabel.
Ich war das schwarze Schaf,
weil ich in der Gewerkschaft war.
Auch wenn
die Gewerkschaft der Uhrenindustrie
nicht besonders kämpferisch war?
Genau, trotzdem,
sie wollten nichts davon hören.
Es war nicht lustig.
So informierte ich
meine Arbeitskolleginnen
während der Pausen
oder auf der Toilette.
Es gab immer irgendeine Gelegenheit.
Ich bin in Biel, im heutigen Zentrum
der Uhrenindustrie.
Ich treffe mich
mit dem CEO der Swatch Group,
dem weltweit führenden
Schweizer Uhrenhersteller.
25'000 Angestellte arbeiten
weltweit für diesen Konzern -
mehr als die Hälfte in der Schweiz.
Was waren Uhren für Sie,
bevor Ihr Vater
in dieses Business eingestiegen ist?
Uhren? Das war v.a. eines:
die Mondlandung.
Da war ich 14.
We choose to go the moon in this
decade and do the other things,
not because they are easy,
but because they are hard.
Bei der Mondlandung 1969 trugen
die Astronauten Schweizer Uhren.
Und als während dem Apollo-13-Flug
die Systeme wegen eines Unfalls
fast ausfielen,
half eine Omega-Uhr beim Navigieren.
Kein Wunder,
war die Dankbarkeit der NASA gross.
Die ganze Welt hat zugehört.
Die hatten natürlich
eine Omega Speedmaster am Arm -
eine Schweizer Uhr.
Wir hatten noch nichts
mit Uhren zu tun.
Ich habe mir das gewünscht
und meine Eltern
schenkten mir eine solche Uhr.
Ich habe diese Uhr immer getragen.
Immer - bis zum Moment,
als die Swatch lanciert wurde.
Dann habe ich angefangen,
Swatch zu tragen.
Vorher gehörte ich
zu der Kategorie von Leuten,
die immer die gleiche Uhr trugen.
Man bekommt eine Uhr,
sie ist schön
und dann behält man sie
ein Leben lang.
Vielleicht bekommt man einmal eine
andere und dann behält man die.
Genau das habe ich durchgemacht,
nämlich den Gewohnheitswechsel.
Meine erste war die Omega
wegen der Mondlandung.
Im gleichen Jahr haben die Schweizer
diese Quarzuhr präsentiert.
Aber für die Schweizer Uhrenbarone
war Quarz nur eine Spielerei.
Sie haben nicht begriffen,
dass die Elektronik die Uhr verändert
und sie präziser macht
als jede mechanische Uhr.
Die Amerikaner und später
auch die Japaner haben das begriffen.
Sie haben den Markt
mit immer billigeren
elektronischen Uhren beliefert.
Die Schweizer Uhrenfabrikanten
waren zu der Zeit
auf dem Höhepunkt ihres Erfolges und
nicht offen für die Quarz-Revolution.
Sie haben lieber Astronauten,
Generäle und Könige
durch ihre Fabriken geführt. So wie
hier das thailändische Königspaar.
An der Basler Mustermesse haben die
Schweizer in den frühen 70er-Jahren
immer extravagantere
und teurere Stücke vorgeführt.
Aber sie konnten noch so glänzen,
die Industrie fiel immer weiter
hinter die Amerikaner
und Japaner zurück.
Mitte der 70er-Jahre
war es dann vorbei.
Fast 60'000 Frauen und Männer
haben ihren Job verloren.
Die Schweizer Industrie schrumpfte
von 90'000 auf 30'000 Angestellte.
Es war traurig.
Ich arbeitete damals bereits
19 Jahre in der Uhrenindustrie.
Es war mein 2. Zuhause.
Die Angst begleitete uns ständig.
Wir hatten keine Ahnung,
wohin wir gehen sollten.
Bei wem arbeiten?
Wir mussten wieder
ganz von vorne beginnen.
Also für Sie war es
überhaupt nicht einfach?
Ja, ich hatte 2 Kinder,
die es zu versorgen galt.
Ich musste um jeden Preis
wieder eine Arbeit finden.
Fabrik um Fabrik wurde geschlossen.
Die beiden grossen Uhrenkonzerne
ASUAG und SSIH waren hochverschuldet.
Ein schlechtes Marketing,
der zu hohe Franken
und die Kurzsichtigkeit der Patrons
wirtschaftete die Industrie zu Boden.
In den Lagerräumen von Omega lagen
Tausende von mechanischen Uhren.
Zu teuer, zu schlecht gemacht.
In Hölstein/BL
ist die Uhrenfirma Oris.
Ein Betrieb,
den es seit über 100 Jahren gibt.
Ihr ehemaliger Chef spricht mit mir,
im Gegensatz zu anderen Unternehmern,
über die Zeit,
in der alles zusammenbrach.
Er selber musste in den 80er-Jahren
die alte Oris liquidieren -
216 Angestellte entlassen.
Er konnte die Firma retten.
Oris geht es heute gut.
Rolf Portmann
kennt aber viele Patrons,
die die Krise nie verwunden haben.
Das war ein persönliches Trauma,
auch für mich.
Das war eine soziale ... sicher
für viele eine soziale Einbusse
oder ein Prestigeverlust.
Das ist eindeutig.
Wie hat sich das
für Sie wahrnehmbar geäussert?
Ein Zurückziehen ins Schneckenhaus.
Äh, bei einigen.
Andere wurden deswegen krank.
Das gab es auch.
Wurden die
eine Art Opfer dieser Krise?
Man war natürlich Opfer und Täter
in einem. Das ist so.
Man musste sich den Vorwurf
gefallen lassen,
man habe viel zu spät auf Quarz
umgestellt und habe das verschlafen.
Äh ...
Insofern wurde man
Opfer der eigenen Strategie,
weil man damals noch auf Mechanik
und auf die Manufakturen setzte.
Das war nachvollziehbar,
von mir aus gesehen.
Denken Sie, man hat nicht gesehen,
welche Fehler man gemacht hat?
Man hat sie vielleicht
schon gesehen,
aber Fehler gesteht man
nicht gerne ein.
Anfangs der 80er-Jahre
tauchte Nicolas Hayek auf.
Er bekam von den Gläubigerbanken der
Konzerne ASUAG und SSIH den Auftrag,
die marode Uhrenindustrie
zu analysieren.
Und so war die Ausgangslage:
Der Markt für mechanische Uhrwerke
brach zusammen.
Zulieferbetriebe im jurassischen
Uhrenbogen standen vor dem Nichts.
Nicolas Hayeks Fazit: fusionieren
und den Billigmarkt erobern.
Er stieg ins Geschäft ein
und wurde Chef des neuen
grossen Uhrenkonzerns SMH.
Ist die Schweizer Uhrenindustrie
am Boden?
Keineswegs,
das Gegenteil ist der Fall.
Ich kann mich erinnern,
an einem Wochenende daheim.
Die Familie sass am Tisch.
Er fragte uns, was wir tun sollten.
Er war jemand,
der keine Schulden machen wollte,
weil er die Unabhängigkeit
behalten wollte.
"Soll ich dort mit investieren?
Soll ich das übernehmen?"
Das war auch, damit man das Konzept,
die Strategie so umsetzt,
wie er das entwickelt hatte.
Wir haben gesagt,
dass er es machen soll.
Er hat an die Strategie geglaubt,
nämlich das unterste Marktsegment
wieder zu beherrschen.
Und sich nicht nur
auf den Luxus zu konzentrieren.
Das ist nicht aufregend, Kinder.
Wir müssen aufregende Uhren machen!
Mit Nicolas Hayek wechselte der Stil.
Er war laut fordernd
und hat gerne provoziert.
Sie haben es nicht einmal
angeschaut. Verdammt noch mal! Nein!
Schauen Sie sie zuerst an,
bevor Sie Nein sagen!
Er war schon eine dominante Figur.
Ja, er war eine Figur ...
Man konnte nachvollziehen,
was er macht.
Und wir waren stolz darauf,
was er machte.
Aber er war auch immer sehr kindlich
und sehr emotional.
Er war wie ein Grizzlybär,
an den man sich anlehnen konnte.
Und er machte "brumm brumm",
er grummelte.
Leute, die den Grizzlybär
nicht kennen, bekommen dann Angst.
Aber sie spüren auch,
dass sie sich an ihm anlehnen wollen
und er sie beschützt.
Nach der Übernahme des neuen Konzerns
präsentiert sich der gebürtige
Libanese 1987 mit seiner Familie
in einer Show
des Schweizer Fernsehens.
Tochter Nayla,
Sohn Nick und Grosssohn Marc -
sie alle werden
in den Konzern einsteigen.
Der Anfang einer neuen Uhrendynastie
in der Schweiz.
Popmusik: "Nothing's gonna
stop me now" von Samantha Fox
Was soll ein Fremder, der von
der Uhrenindustrie nichts versteht,
der Uhrenindustrie jetzt bringen?
Man schüttelte den Kopf und sagte:
"Das kann nicht gut kommen."
Was dachten Sie?
Ich dachte, ich kann mir gar
kein Bild über diesen Mann machen,
ich kenne ihn ja nicht.
Aber ich dachte, dass durch die
Fusion durchaus ein Chance besteht.
Doch auch in gewissen Gremien,
in denen ich sass, hiess es:
Nein, das ist ja unmöglich.
Würde das in den USA passieren,
hätte Hayek als Insider
eine neue Justizgeschichte am Hals.
Es ist auch Neid aufgekommen.
Aber das änderte sich bald.
Herr Portmann von Oris sagt,
mit Herrn Hayek, Herrn Thomke usw.
sei eine neue Kultur gekommen.
Was war das für eine Kultur?
Dass man Mut hat,
etwas Neues zu machen
und es nicht mehr Schein
als Sein ist.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Sie wollten etwas bewegen, eine
Industrie erhalten, vorwärtsgehen.
Hatte er nicht manchmal auch
das Gefühl, er mache etwas kaputt?
Nein, die bestehende Kultur
war verheerend.
Diese musste man zerstören.
In dieser Kultur hatte man
das Gefühl, man sei die Könige.
Das konnte man
auch Karikaturen entnehmen,
dass sie quasi mit einem 100-Fr.-
Schein ihre Zigarre anzünden.
Es ist ein Paradebeispiel
von Leuten, die meinen,
sie können ihre Produkte immer -
auch ohne Innovationen -
teurer und teurer verkaufen.
Es reiche, dass sie in der Schweiz
produziert wurden.
Ein wunderbares "Swiss made",
ein bisschen mehr Gold,
ein bisschen "Wheeler Dealer -
und das reiche,
um immer mehr Gewinn zu erzielen.
Mit denen
wollte er nichts zu tun haben?
Nein, so war es nicht.
Sie haben sich ja selber abgesägt.
Die ganze Industrie
lief in die Pleite.
Es gab damals Uhrenbarone
mit riesigen Schlössern,
mit Besitztümern.
Und gleichzeitig
ging das Ganze bachab.
Während man sich
in der Chefetage fragte,
ob es die mechanische Uhr
noch brauche,
tüftelten die Uhrmacher weiter.
Sie glaubten an ihr Handwerk.
Bei IWC Schaffhausen war es Kurt
Klaus, der mit seinen Erfindungen
der mechanischen Uhr und der Firma
einen neuen Schub gab.
Seine Kreationen sind
im firmeneigenen Museum ausgestellt.
Hier haben wir das Andenken
an die Da Vinci.
Das sind verschiedene Modelle
von uns.
Er baute über ein halbes Jahrtausend
in eine Armbanduhr.
Er programmierte die Zukunft,
inklusive einer exakten Anzeige
der Mondphasen.
Da Vinci taufte er seine Uhr.
Wir habe vorher, eigentlich
in der ganzen Geschichte der IWC,
darum gekämpft, die genausten Uhren
zu produzieren, die möglich sind.
Da waren wir gegen die Quarzuhren
chancenlos.
Dann mussten wir uns überlegen,
was wir machen können,
damit die Uhren,
die mechanischen Uhren,
wieder attraktiv werden.
Und so habe ich einmal spät in der
Nacht, sogar an einem freien Tag,
weil es anders nicht möglich war -
wir arbeiteten damals
ja nur 4 Tage die Woche ...
Kurzarbeit?
Ja, genau.
An diesem Tag versuchte ich,
ein Taschenuhrwerk
mit einem Kalendarium zu versehen.
Und es funktionierte dann sogar.
Glücklicherweise wurde es dann auch
von der Geschäftsleitung
so aufgenommen, dass sie sagten:
"Wir sollten eigentlich mal
probieren, so etwas zu machen."
Kurt Klaus
ist schon längstens pensioniert.
Aber für die Marketingabteilung
der IWC ist er Gold wert.
Seit über 10 Jahren erzählt er
in der ganzen Welt von seinen Uhren,
die so aufwendig sind
in der Herstellung,
aber nie so präzise sein werden
wie ein billige Quarzuhr.
Was nützt einem eine Uhr
mit einem ewigen Kalender?
Was bringt einem das -
für fast die Ewigkeit?
Es gibt einem vielleicht
einen Überblick auf eine Zeit,
die weiter geht,
als wir erfassen können.
Es ist die Faszination,
dass diese Uhr das machen könnte.
Z.B. vor 11 Jahren,
bei der Jahrtausendwende,
war es ein Ereignis mit der Da Vinci
mit ihrem ewigen Kalender.
Natürlich alle,
die eine solche Uhr besassen,
haben in der Silvesternacht
auf sie geblickt und gesehen,
wie langsam die Zahl 19 verschwindet
und auf die Zahl 20 wechselt.
Und das ist einfach ein Erlebnis.
Ich würde mir wünschen, ich würde
das nochmals erleben, aber ...
Dass es nochmals vorwärts geht.
Aber es geht einfach nicht.
Es geht zu lange, bis sich
dieser Vorgang wieder abspielt.
Was die Da Vinci für den Luxusmarkt,
ist die Swatch für den Billigmarkt.
Ticken
Die Geschichte von Swatch
begann vor Nicolas Hayek,
nämlich Ende der 70er-Jahre
bei der ETA,
der Herstellerin von
mechanischen Uhrwerken in Grenchen.
Der damalige Direktor Ernst Thomke
gab den Auftrag,
eine billige Uhr zu produzieren.
2 junge Ingenieure schaffen es,
Elmar Mock und Jacques Müller.
Das sind die ersten Swatch.
Da ist immer diese berühmte Schale,
in die alles eingebaut wurde.
Und die verschiedenen Farben,
die ganz zu Beginn verwendet wurden.
Wenn ich mich recht erinnere,
gab es schon Ende 1979 die
ersten Befehle aus der Direktion,
eine Schweizer Uhr zu entwickeln,
die nichts kostet
und qualitativ hervorragend ist.
Das war - so ungefähr - der Auftrag.
Die Tüftelei von Jacques Müller
und Elmar Mock
ging als "Schnapsidee"
in die Geschichte ein.
Eine Uhr mit wenig Einzelteilen,
robust und industriell hergestellt
für 5 Fr. das Stück.
Diese "Schnapsidee",
das ist genau die Skizze,
die ich an jenem Tag machte.
Zuerst hat mich Thomke
zusammengestaucht.
Ich war sein Punchingball.
Er fragte mich,
ob ich wahnsinnig sei,
irgendeine Idee von Geld habe,
warum ich hier arbeite.
Ich wurde zusammengestaucht,
das Papier hat Thomke behalten.
Ich ging zu Müller zurück in der
Meinung, es sei schiefgegangen.
2 Std. später
kam der technische Direktor,
mit dem ich zuvor
noch nie ein Gespräch hatte:
"Ah, Sie wollen spielen? Okay."
"Herr Thomke will in 6 Monaten
alle Zeichnungen haben."
"Sie verlieren alle Projekte."
"Priorität hat für Sie nur noch,
das zu organisieren."
Am Anfang
waren alle anderen dagegen.
Wir waren wirklich isoliert.
Nach jedem Arbeitstag mussten wir
Bilanz ziehen und ich fragte mich:
Bin ich normal oder die anderen?
Alle Welt war gegen uns.
Und es war schwierig
und brauchte Kraft,
den eingeschlagenen Weg
weiterzugehen.
6 Monate später
hatten wir Prototypen,
deren Zeiger
in die falsche Richtung liefen.
So schlecht war unsere Konstruktion.
Dann bekamen wir nochmals 6 Monate
und endlich hatten wir Prototypen,
die funktionierten.
Die 5 Stück überlebten 3 Tage.
Thomke meinte:
"Okay, wenn sie 3 Tage überlebt
haben, werden sie funktionieren.
Popmusik
Swatch ist mehr als eine Billiguhr.
Sie ein Lebensgefühl,
ein Modeaccessoire.
Die Botschaft ist alles in der
restrukturierten Uhrenindustrie.
Keiner wusste das besser
als Nicolas Hayek.
Er machte das Marketing
und den Vertrieb
zu den Hauptpfeilern
seiner Industriepolitik.
So stieg er
zum Schweizer Uhrenkönig auf.
Er behielt recht mit seiner These,
dass nur, wer Massen produziert,
der Industrie einen Boden geben kann.
Und auch, dass das mit Uhren
aus der Schweiz möglich ist.
Und jetzt
ist die 100-millionste ...
1994 signiert er
die 100-millionste Swatch.
Das ist
das neue Schweizer Kultobjekt.
2010, nur ein paar Monate
nach dem Tode von Nicolas Hayek,
kamen auch die Erfinder der Swatch
zur ihren Ehren.
Elmar Mock und Jacques Müller
erhielten den Prix Gaia,
eine Art Oscar der Uhrenbranche.
Das hat mich gefreut.
Es macht Freude, dass man einen
solchen Preis nicht posthum erhält.
Es ist schon besser,
wenn man noch lebt.
Eine Anerkennung für einen Erfinder,
1'000 Jahre später.
Ich musste etwas schmunzeln.
Ich muss Ihnen gestehen ...
Zu Beginn wollten Sie
den Preis gar nicht annehmen?
Nein.
Natürlich schätzt man die Geste.
Wir sind alle irgendwo Egoisten.
Es hat geholfen,
Klarheit zu schaffen,
bei all diesen vermeintlichen Vätern
der Swatch
und hat ein paar Dinge
richtiggestellt.
Was bedeutet die Swatch
für Ihre Firma heute?
Sie können es ableiten.
Die Swatch Group
heisst Swatch Group,
weil wir dazu stehen, obwohl wir
der grösste Uhrenkonzern sind.
Die Swatch macht nicht mehr
den grössten Umsatz im Konzern,
andere Marken stehen vor der Swatch.
Trotzdem ist die Philosophie
des Konzerns immer noch: Swatch.
D.h.: Massenproduktion
bringt Innovation.
Ob sie im Wert so viel wächst
wie eine Omega oder Breguet,
ist nicht wichtig für die Swatch.
Wichtig ist,
dass sie stückzahlmässig wächst.
Denn das gibt uns die Möglichkeit,
die industrielle Basis
zu verbreitern.
Der Konzern will
in allen Preissegmenten präsent sein
und alle Bestandteile
für elektronische und
mechanische Uhren selber herstellen.
Ein gutes Beispiel dafür
ist die Firma Nivarox
in Fontaines im Neuenburger Jura.
Hier zeigt sich eindrücklich, wie
dominant die Swatch Group heute ist.
Christian Feuvrier und Roger Juillet
führen mich
durch das Hightech-Unternehmen,
in dem rund 1'000 Angestellte
arbeiten.
Modernste Maschinen produzieren die
kleinsten und exklusivsten Teilchen
für mechanische Uhren.
Bestandteile für die Uhrwerke,
Zifferblätter oder Schrauben,
mehr als 1'000 Stück
aus 1 g Gold.
Das exklusivste Stück des
Unternehmens ist die sog. Spirale.
Die Spirale treibt das Uhrwerk an.
Sie gehört zum Herzen
der mechanischen Uhr.
Wem die begehrte Spirale
verkauft wird,
auf die keine mechanische Uhr
verzichten kann
und ein grosses Wissen
zur Herstellung braucht,
entscheidet alleine die Swatch Group.
Christian Feuvrier
platzt fast vor Stolz,
als er mir das Rohmaterial
der Wunder-Spirale zeigt.
Das ist unser Tresor.
Aus diesem Draht
wird die Spirale hergestellt.
Diesen Draht zu bändigen,
ist unsere wichtigste Aufgabe.
Was kostet denn so eine Drahtrolle?
Mehrere 10'000 Fr.
Und aus diesem Draht kann man jetzt
die Spirale fertigen?
Genau. Aber es braucht noch
einige Arbeitsgänge bis zur Spirale.
Das ist das Grundmaterial,
der berühmte Draht,
aus dem das Herz der Uhr
gemacht wird.
Und das ist ein grosses Merci
von uns an Herrn Hayek,
der an uns geglaubt hat.
In diesem Raum geben die sog. Reg-
leusen der Spirale die präzise Form.
Ich erfahre zu meiner Überraschung,
dass Frauenhände präziser sind
als die modernsten Maschinen.
Wir beliefern Hersteller
aller Marken.
Insbesondere Breguet, der die
meisten dieser Spiralen braucht.
Mit einer maschinell
gebogenen Spirale
weicht eine Uhr pro Tag 4 Sek. ab.
Mit einer von Hand gerichteten
ist es nur 1 Sek. pro Tag.
Die Spirale muss von Hand bearbeitet
werden wegen der Präzision.
Man muss ihr eine Form geben,
sie biegen.
Und das ist sehr individuell.
Jede Spirale reagiert anders?
Nein, jede reagiert gleich.
Aber je nachdem, wo man sie berührt,
reagiert sie anders.
Die Regleuse
muss unterschiedlich korrigieren.
Man könnte sagen,
die Spirale ist lebendig.
Wenn man sie biegt, hängt alles vom
Druck ab, mit dem man sie berührt.
Je nachdem reagiert sie.
Es braucht besonderes Geschick,
um eine Spirale von Hand zu biegen.
Das gelingt nicht sofort.
Im Schnitt braucht es 1 - 1 1/2 Std.
Das ist die Schwierigkeit.
An der Baselworld 2011,
der grössten Uhrenmesse der Welt,
ist das Interesse
an Schweizer Uhren gross.
Der Uhrenindustrie
geht es wieder bestens.
Sie beschäftigt über 50'000 Personen.
Die meisten Uhrenmarken
gehören heute zu 3 grossen Konzernen.
Nur ein paar - wie die grosse
alte Traditionsmarke Rolex -
blieben unabhängig.
Unübersehbar ist die Dominanz
der Swatch Group.
Ihr allein gehören 19 Uhrenmarken.
Gegen Dominanz hat man ja nichts.
Sondern: Ist sie im Interesse
des Gesamtgebildes?
Hat sich die ganze Uhrenindustrie
in der Schweiz entwickelt?
Sie hat sich fantastisch entwickelt.
Wir sorgen dafür,
dass der Gesamtkuchen grösser wird.
Es geht nicht um einen Verdrängungs-
wettkampf in einer Industrie.
Sondern: Auf der Welt
kämpft die Schweizer Uhrenindustrie
gegen die japanische, die indische
und die chinesische Uhrenindustrie.
Sie haben auch Produkte,
die auf den Markt kommen.
Sie wollen auch
Marktanteile gewinnen.
Wir in der Schweiz
haben alle das Interesse,
dass wir vorwärtsgehen.
Und wenn Sie schauen, um wie viel
dieser Markt gewachsen ist:
Heute hat es viel mehr Platz
für viele kleine Unternehmen.
Viel mehr Platz auch für die grossen
- und jeder macht Wachstum.
Zum Schluss fahre ich ein letztes Mal
ins Vallee de Joux, wo alles begann.
Uhrmacher Louis Caillet lud mich
in seine persönliche Werkstatt ein,
in seine Schatzhöhle:
Et ici?
C'est de la recuperation
de machines ...
De partout?
De partout, oui.
An allen Orten
hat er mechanische Ware,
die er sein Leben lang sammelte.
Nicht zuletzt darum,
damit er genügend Ersatzteile hat,
um die alten Maschinen
in seiner Werkstatt zu reparieren.
Pour vous, ce quoi ici?
Hier ist mein Paradies.
Das heisst?
Das heisst,
dass es mir hier gut geht.
Hier vergesse ich den Stress,
den ich tagsüber hatte.
Hier bin ich zu nichts verpflichtet.
Wenn ich nichts machen will,
dann mache ich nichts.
Gibt es Momente,
an denen Sie nichts machen?
Ja, ja. Manchmal schaue ich
nur ein bisschen rum
oder suche etwas in einer Schublade.
Tue so, als ob ich arbeiten würde.
Für Louis Caillet steht die Zeit auch
nach der Pensionierung nicht still.
Er wird seine Passion weiterpflegen.
Und endlich eine Breguet-Uhr bauen -
ganz für sich allen.